this house is huge Cindy we hit the
mother lode
what now what's going on out here Trick
or Treat trick or treat
preferably treat what it's 11 o'clock at
night now how did you get past security
sir we've got a lot of stops to make so
all these questions not really speeding
things along my dad says you're a
socialist what say that yeah yeah no
what's your dad's night Peter well no
how about you tell Peter that he's gonna
get a nice little auditing this year
trick or treat
all right see now no it's it's to latent
what wanting to get all that candy
where'd you get all that dude it's
Halloween Halloween trick-or-treat no no
now see that's way too much candy for
just one kid someone have to take some
of that loves candy I'm giving em to
other kids in the neighborhood who
didn't go out and get candy for
themselves what it's it's Halloween they
can get their own candy but what about
kids less fortunate than you it's it's
free well now maybe if we're kids like
you who can afford costumes
hey hey commander-in-chief there do you
see my eye patch hmm it's felt okay
we're not exactly running a Disney
budget on this one here I mean take a
look at my sister's tiara shilling quite
have Jim Henson on the payroll if you
know what I mean happy Halloween yeah
besides you've got like two punch bowls
of candy back there can't you just give
some of those away have you given away
any of your candy tonight
and he at all or all right all right
stop no let's go down with the questions
I can't think straight now you know what
it feels like to be Joe Biden Hey
okay how about this now how about I give
you some candy and then I'll take half
and give you credit towards getting some
new candy
how about that hmm well you drive a hard
bargain I'll tell you that you drive a
hard bargain but you seem honest so so
how about bite me trick or treat
you're not getting my kin okay come on
Cindy let's go we'll see actually I am
what are you talking about well now if
you don't as soon as I close this door
I'm gonna notify security and then
you'll be tackled tased searched and
they're gonna conference get your candy
anyway you wouldn't oh but I would
no probably gonna send you to get moe I
thought your clothes getting out nope
this is the worst Halloween ever
now come on now I'll give you 12 cents
for your UNICEF my god you're cheap
trick or treat hmm trick or treat